eine frau schreit verzweifelt um hilfe
bitte bringt mich hier raus das video
entstand hier in wentworth hospital in
durban/südafrika gefilmt hat offenbar
ein anderer patient die aufnahmen sind
schwer zu ertragen
[Musik]
ich komme hier nicht raus ruft sie und
ich werde so sterben
rubina hocke kam am 4
januar ins krankenhaus wegen
atemproblemen
sie starb zwei tage später an einem
herzinfarkt
das video zeigt wie sie nach hilfe
schreit doch niemand kommt auch andere
patienten sind zu sehen
eine person liegt zugedeckt am boden
zustand unbekannt die behörden erklären
später das krankenhaus sei völlig
unterbesetzt gewesen fast 30 ärzte und
schwestern vierten wegen kobelt
das video steht für nur einen fall von
vielen
das gesundheitssystem ist teilweise
völlig überlastet und wieso ist die
todesrate so hoch welche rolle spielt
die südafrikanische variante des virus
das wollen wir herausfinden
[Musik]
wir sind in alberten etwas außerhalb von
johannesburg
hier lebt peter moser mit ihren drei
erwachsenen kindern
während draußen langsam die sonne
aufgeht bereitet sie sich darauf vor
ihre schicht anzutreten
die 48-jährige ist krankenschwester
eigentlich in der orthopädie noch als im
märz 2020 die erste welle beginnt wird
ihre abteilung zu einer corvette station
wir haben verdachtsfälle aufgenommen
als der erste patient positiv getestet
wurde
wir hatten alle angst ich hatte angst um
mein leben angst um meine kinder angst
die krankheit zu bekommen und sie nach
hause zu bringen
ich hatte angst zu sterben
alle hatten angst die angst ist ein
ständiger begleiter bevor sie zur arbeit
fährt betet sie um schutz für sich ihre
familie ihre kollegen
der druck auf die krankenschwestern ist
riesig sagt tabitha muss anna ihre
station hat 28 betten alle seien belegt
das krankenhaus stelle ihnen zwar
schutzausrüstung zur verfügung doch
manchmal gebe es probleme
im moment haben wir das problem dass die
ganzkörperanzüge ausgegangen sind
wir improvisieren zum glück ist der
kittel so lang dass er bis zu den füßen
reicht
er deckt alles oberhalb der schule ab es
wird improvisiert
ich würde sagen es ist relativ sicher
aber nicht sicher
[Musik]
im radio läuft ein gospelsong
herr sei bei mir singt sie inspiriere
mich herr
[Musik]
ich habe angst ich hatte selbst noch
kein ko wird aber ich glaube dass meine
mutter daran gestorben ist
ich habe sie im august 2020 begraben
sie hatte alle symptome von corvette sie
lebte nicht hier sondern am ostkap ich
komme vom ostkap aber ich arbeite hier
ich war so wütend ich helfe hier den
menschen konnte aber meine eigenen
mutter nicht helfen weil sie dort lebt
ich war so wütend aber ich muss darüber
hinwegkommen
ich denke mit der zeit werde ich darüber
hinweg kommen
es ist sehr beängstigend und ich frage
mich wer in meiner familie der nächste
erst um halb sieben erreicht sie das
täle mariane krankenhaus in dem sie
arbeitet ihre schicht dauert zwölf
stunden drinnen filmen dürfen wir nicht
viele krankenhäuser haben ihre
belastungsgrenze erreicht manche haben
sie überschritten krankenschwestern
pfleger und ärzte trauen sich nur selten
die zustände zu schildern
sie haben angst ihren job zu verlieren
sagt le rat um tun sie sie ist
präsidentin einer krankenschwestern und
pfleger gewerkschaft und erzählt uns was
die betroffenen sich nicht zu sagen
trauen
wie kann ich weiß dann sagen uns dass
sie extrem ausgebrannt sind
sie fühlen sich von der regierung im
stich gelassen weil die von anfang an
nicht für ihre sicherheit gesorgt hat
die vorhandenen vorräte an
schutzausrüstung sind noch immer nicht
adäquat viele krankenschwestern haben
uns erzählt dass sie nur eine op maske
bekommen die man eigentlich nur vier
stunden trägt und sie sollen sie
tagelang tragen bevor sie eine neue
bekommen mit fatalen folgen mehr als
41.000 ärzte pfleger und schwestern
haben sich offiziellen zahlen zufolge
allein im vergangenen jahr infiziert die
ansteckungskette sei alarmierend sagte
rath und tun sie das ministerium hat
eine statistik veröffentlicht wie viele
mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen
krank geworden und wie viele gestorben
sind
das war letztes jahr die kommen mit dem
zählen gar nicht hinterher
wir hatten eine stationen barack obamas
krankenhaus wo alle 20 30 schwestern auf
einmal positiv getestet wurden eine von
ihnen stark das sagt viel darüber aus
dass die ansteckungsrate trotz aller
maßnahmen alarmieren ist die
infektionszahlen lagen zeitweise bei
über 20.000 täglich mittlerweile sind
sie deutlich gesunken
trotzdem sind viele krankenhäuser völlig
überlastet manche haben zelte aufgebaut
um mehr patienten versorgen zu können
auch sauerstoff gibt es doch es fehlt an
personal intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte der kapazitäten sind so
angespannt dass wir an einem punkt sind
dass wir nicht einmal die unterbringen
können die in einem kritischen zustand
sind
das heißt im grunde müssen sie sich
hinten anstellen und hoffen dass ein
anderer patient stirbt damit ihr leben
gerettet werden kann
immer wieder kommt hilfe zu spät weil
das system überlastet ist die todesrate
ist außergewöhnlich hoch
weltweit liegt sie im schnitt bei 2,2
prozent in südafrika sind es rund 3
wir wollen wissen warum die
infektionszahlen zeitweise so in die
höhe geschossen sind und fahren nach
durban
hier sitzt das christ das kwazulu-natal
zentrum für forschung innovation und
sequenzierung hier findet forschung auf
weltklasse niveau statt
professor tulio der oliviera und sein
team untersuchen jede woche hunderte
proben des chores im zentrum steht die
sogenannte sequenzierung jede woche
erhalten wir proben aus etwa 100
kliniken aus dem ganzen land die bringen
wir ins labor so dass wir noch in
derselben woche das genom des virus
haben wir untersuchen in einem
konstanten prozess wie die genetische
diversität des virus aussieht die
sequenzierung erlaubt uns die
verschiedenen varianten und ihre
spezifischen mutationen zu
identifizieren
hier in diesem labor wurde die neue
südafrikanische variante entdeckt sie
breite sich viel schneller aus als die
alte sagt professor tulio der olivier
besondere sorge bereiten den forschern
sogenannte escape musicians mutationen
die es dem virus erleichtern der
immunabwehr zu entkommen
wir denken dass einige mutationen die
wir hier in südafrika haben ist dem
stachel protein erlauben sich besser an
den zeller anzuheften und schneller in
sie einzudringen und weil es sich fester
mit der leeze alle verbindet kommen die
antikörper nicht dazwischen und die
neutralisation ist schlecht in südafrika
habe die neue variante quasi alle
vorherigen verdrängt nachdem was die
forscher bisher wissen ist die neue
variante aber nicht tödlicher als die
ursprüngliche wir glauben dass die neuen
varianten der in südafrika und in
großbritannien dieselbe krankheit und
die selben symptome auslösen
das problem ist dass wenn zu viele
menschen gleichzeitig ins krankenhaus
müssen sind die krankenhäuser überlastet
dann gibt es eine höhere sterblichkeit
nicht wegen der
sondern weil für die borussia sie nicht
genug betten zur verfügung stehen
die forscher gehen auch der frage nach
ob die jetzigen impfstoffe gegen die
südafrikanische variante wirken
bislang sind sie optimistisch allerdings
könnte die wirkung schwächer sein dann
wäre es vorstellbar den impfstoff jedes
jahr anzupassen so wie bei der grippe
finanziell und logistisch wäre das für
ärmere länder allerdings kaum zu stemmen
auf die impfstoffe und ein ende der
pandemie hofft vor allem die schwer
gebeutelte tourismusbranche
wir sind immer dicke wildreservat hier
liegt der etat lisa charlotte thalia
heißt übersetzt ort der neuen anfänger
doch im moment steht alles still
gerade mal zwei gäste sind da der rest
steht leer
wegen der neuen virus variante haben
zahlreiche länder den flugverkehr mit
südafrika eingestellt die kunden aus
europa kanada und den usa fehlen
die zahl der gäste ist weit runter
gegangen es sind fast nur südafrikaner
da der markt aus übersee fehlt und das
sind 95 prozent unserer gäste
die wenigen gäste die überhaupt kommen
tun das oft kurzfristig denn cobit und
mögliche lockdown machen langfristiges
planen unmöglich das erschwert die
logistik für die lodge das richtige
essen die richtigen produkte und das
personal hier zu haben um angebot und
nachfrage zusammenzubringen ist
planungstechnisch die größte
schwierigkeit die wir haben mark junis
und rafah romanos haben sich durch ko
witt nicht davon abhalten lassen zu
reisen
sie leben in pretoria gut vier stunden
entfernt vom madegwa park und sind für
ein langes wochenende gekommen
ich bin vorsichtig was ansteckung angeht
aber ich glaube dass man an einem ort
wie diesem ein niedrigeres risiko hat
als in der stadt wegen des weiten raums
und hier sind nur wenige menschen ich
denke es ist hier sichere ich denke dass
es uns stärker macht hier frische luft
zu atmen in der natur zu sein
ich denke die gefahr ist in der stadt
hier können wir entspannen und die natur
genießen
darius mbeki und sein kollege thema zu
arbeiten als ranger für die lodge da die
touristen fehlen sind sie nur sporadisch
im einsatz und verdienen weniger als
sonst
es ist sehr schwierig eine
herausforderung wenn das geschäft nicht
gut läuft so wie früher dann heißt das
keine gehälter
es hat enorme negative auswirkungen auf
unser leben so wie ihnen geht es
unzähligen ranger und anderen
mitarbeitern in den lodges die jetzt
ganz oder teilweise arbeitslos sind und
immer hängen ganze familien drama das
gehalt versorgt eine ganze familie
sie alle hängen von einer person ab die
alle versorgt wenn da nichts mehr kommt
ist das ein großes problem
stopps entlang und darius sind froh dass
agca und markt da sind und geben alles
um atemberaubende begegnungen zu
ermöglichen
so wie diese
eine nashornmutter oder kalb schlendern
direkt vor das papier
das war eine unglaubliche erfahrung sie
so nah zu sehen und sie sahen fast schon
prähistorisch aus das war wirklich eine
besondere erfahrung und dann auch noch
geparden zum sonnenuntergang mehr world
live geht nicht
zurück in johannesburg wir treffen
maggie may appel
sie ist ärztin und leitet eine
privatklinik
die 61 jährige hatte ein digitales
denkmal ins leben gerufen für
mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen die
im kampf gegen corbett verstorben sind
[Musik]
die tränen zu sehen die seelenqual den
schmerz mir ist aufgefallen dass wir so
was nicht haben und ich dachte es ist
zeit das selbstlose opfer der
mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen
weltweit zusammen zu führen und dieses
denkmal zu schaffen
[Musik]
es ist ein youtube film mit dem namen
und gesichtern der verstorbenen
ob professoren ärzte schwestern oder
pfleger sie alle haben im
gesundheitswesen gearbeitet
[Musik]
angehörige aber auch krankenhäuser und
ärzte schicken ihr die informationen zu
den verstorbenen und es werden immer
mehr
[Musik]
seit neuer kommen die fälle von kollegen
die verstorben sind heftig schnell und
in hoher zahlen und was auch wichtig ist
es dass wir sehen wie auch die jungen
mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen
sterben
anders als in der ersten welle wo es vor
allem ältere pfleger ärzte sanitäter und
so warnen wenn sie die namen der
verstorbenen kollegen sie kommen mir die
tränen
maggie may apero ist aber auch wütend
das denkmal sei auch ein aufruf zu
handeln
es gab fälle wo ärzte oder schwestern
nach betten suchten von krankenhaus zu
krankenhaus fuhren private und
öffentliche auf der suche nach einem
freien bett aber sie fanden keins was
für ein paradox also sagen wir in
unserem manifest dass jedes krankenhaus
ein oder zwei betten frei halten sollte
für mitarbeiter aus dem gesundheitswesen
für menschen wie die mutter von conny
tempo und paris akustiker sie war
krankenschwester und infizierte sich im
juli bei der arbeit mit cobit als sie
krank wird bringen ihre töchter sie zum
krankenhaus doch weil ihre mutter
positiv getestet wurde will sie zunächst
niemand behandeln sie sagte dass sie
schmerzen hat doch sie taten nichts sie
verschränkten armen schwestern und ärzte
standen da und taten nichts
das war s zerreißen ich weiß dass meine
normen für ihre patienten alles getan
hat und sie bekam diese behandlung nicht
während ihre mutter auf hilfe wartet
verschlechtert sich ihr zustand
sie bekommt nicht mehr richtig luft wir
sind fast ausgerastet erzählt per leeze
akkus ihr ich habe geschrien sie kann
nicht atmen
erst da holten sie eine liege und ein
sauerstoff
die 34 jährige ruft einen freund an der
in dem krankenhaus arbeitet fragt ihn
was jetzt mit ihrer mutter passiert man
hatte mir gesagt sie würden sie auf die
intensivstation bringen aber mein freund
sagte mir dass das gar nicht geht weil
sie dort keine freien betten haben ihre
mutter starb am selben tag
sie war gerade mal 57 ihre älteste
tochter von ecosia infizierte sich
vermutlich bei ihr als sie zum testen in
die klinik von dr mutter pelo geht
erfährt sie von dem digitalen denkmal
was doktormutter pilot für uns getan hat
ist unbeschreiblich ich weiß sicher
meine mutter ist für etwas gutes
gestorben
sie hat sich um menschen gekümmert
sie ist eine heldin eines wahnsinns frau
das denkmal ist ein trost für die
schwestern
stellen sie sich vor eines tages haben
wir kinder
wir werden ins internet gehen und paris
wird ihren kindern das zeigen zusätzlich
zu den fotos die ihr zuhause haben
sie werden sagen das war unsere
großmutter und so ist sie gestorben
teilt aufnahmen vom märz kombico seal
sind für ihren enkel ein lied dieser
corona vier monate später war sie tot
hier hat sie gearbeitet im täle morgane
krankenhaus genau wie tabitha muss sana
die sonne geht langsam unter als sie
nach hause fährt zum glück hat mir heute
keine toten
zum glück für uns meistens haben 34 tote
am tag
aber heute war ein guter tag
der tag war hektisch und anstrengend
aber machbar sagt sie und ich bin
erschöpft emotional und körperlich
als sie zu hause ankommt empfängt ihr
sohn sie im garten hilft ihr beim
desinfiziert hände
erst dann geht sie ins haus wenn ich
reingehe fasse ich nichts an
ich ziehe alles aus so dass das virus
nicht entweichen
ich gehe direkt und erst danach setzte
ich mich
ich setze mich nirgendwo hin vor dem
duschen den abend verbringt anita moser
mit ihren kindern und wirkt sich aus
morgen geht es wieder früh los
[Musik]